- In light of the upcoming holiday,
this is a song.
♫ Halloween's around the corner
♫ And we all know what that means,
♫ Tons of sexy versions
♫ Of things
♫ That shouldn't be.
♫ But instead of trying to fight it,
♫ Everybody seems to invite it,
♫ Making Halloween the most hellacious day
♫ The world has ever seen.
♫ Wanna be Minnie Mouse,
♫ Just lose the blouse,
♫ And make the outfit truly a mini
♫ Because nothing's
♫ Fucking sacred anymore.
♫ Or be the starfish named Patrick,
♫ Just a bikini bottom is the trick,
♫ To let everybody know
♫ that you're a horrible dresser.
♫ There's nothing about Charlie Brown
♫ That should be sexy.
♫ He's a bald child fighting depression,
♫ Not an object, don't be a blockhead.
♫ And Mario wouldn't be caught dead
♫ Fighting Bowser
♫ In such tiny trousers,
♫ Although he's great at riding pipes.
♫ Halloween can be sexy,
♫ But we've taken it
♫ Way too far.
♫ Halloween can be sexy,
♫ But we've taken it way too far.
♫ Case in point,
♫ Hermione was a heroine
dedicated to education.
♫ She wouldn't open up her Gryffindor
♫ And let just anybody
♫ Slither in,
♫ Or put that
♫ Ravenclaw
♫ Into that
♫ Hufflepuff♫
- Ok, let's keep it a little more--
- Oh, oh. Too many--
- [Guitarist] A few too many
- [Singer] innuendos?
- Harry Potter innuendos to be
- [Singer] Ok. Ok, yeah.
- No, you're right. You're right.
- [Guitarist] Yeah.
- You're right. You're
right. You're right.
♫ And nobody wants to do Scooby.
♫ And Mary Poppins would be ashamed.
♫ Being sexy,
♫ Doesn't mean being classless.
♫ That outfit's assless.
♫ How do we get past this?
♫ You might not get a treat
♫ When you look like
♫ You're trying to turn a trick
♫ But if you must be a sexy something,
♫ And wish to truly rise above,
♫ Might I suggest
♫ The ladybug?
♫ The sexy
♫ Ladybug?
♫ Halloween can be sexy,
♫ But we've taken it
♫ Way too far!
♫ Halloween can be sexy,
♫ But we've taken it
♫ Way too far.
♫ Halloween can by sexy,
♫ But we've taken it
♫ Way too far.
♫ Halloween can be sexy,
♫ But we've taken it
♫ Way too
♫ Far♫
(heavy rock music)
- (sighs) Happy Halloween, I guess.
- [Voiceover] Dude, that first
jump was fuckin' so sick--
- [Singer] Yeah, you guys
- [Voiceover] You guys--
- [Singer] jumped super well.
- [Voiceover] awesome.
- - That was really good jumping.
- [Voiceover] That was so sick.